about a hundred years ago leading
entrepreneurs from the gilded age like
rockefeller and andrew carnegie
were fighting to become the world's
first billionaire
this is a title that john d rockefeller
the founder of standard oil
would end up claiming in 1916. 100 years
later
we are starting to see the race to
trillionaire status slowly brewing up
now this isn't to say that today's
leading billionaires aren't any richer
as the billionaires from the guild of
age are multiples above today's top
billionaires
after accounting for inflation but
nonetheless
who will win the race to 1 trillion
[Music]
well starting off just taking a glance
at the billionaires list
it becomes clear that the fastest
growing billionaires by far
are jeff bezos and elon musk with the
meech gaining 80 billion
and 60 billion respectively just this
year the other billionaires at the top
though still making tens of billions
themselves are gaining just a fraction
of this
this is because they're either so
diversified that they match market
performance
or their companies have matured to a
point where the exponential growth is
mostly over
as a result currently the most likely
candidates to reach 1 trillion first
are jeff bezos and elon musk starting
with jeff bezos
he has had a tremendous run-up over the
past 22 years
growing amazon from not even a billion
dollar company to a trillion dollar
company
of course to match this exponential
growth amazon must have mind-boggling
yearly growth numbers
which they do with the average relay
growth of 82 percent
however that doesn't actually mean that
they go 82
per year because negative growth numbers
are worth significantly more
than positive growth numbers for
instance let's say a company grew 900
one year and then pull back 80 the
following year
if the company was worth 100 originally
at the end of the first year
it would be worth one thousand dollars
after 900 growth
but after the second year an 80 pullback
would bring it back to just two hundred
dollars
despite eighty percent being less than
ten percent of nine hundred percent
the average return during this period
would be four hundred and ten percent
but we know that this is now reflective
of the company's real growth
during this time period the company's
overall growth is actually 100 percent
which is the same as 41.42 per year
which is still very impressive but
clearly nowhere near the 400
average return so to calculate amazon's
real return per year
we have to look at how much an
investment would have grown during the
company's life
if you put in just 100 into amazon when
it became public
you would have 65 538
today or about 65 000 growth
spreading that over 22 years we get an
annualized return
of 34.28 or nearly five
times the market using this growth rate
in conjunction with jeff's current
wealth of 195 billion
we see that jeff bezos could reach the
trillion dollar mark in just
five and a half years or near the
beginning of 2026
but the thing is most of amazon's growth
is already done in fact
amazon stock stagnated at eighteen
hundred to two thousand dollars per
share for about a year and a half
and if it weren't for the pandemic
driving more online sales
this would likely still be the case
moreover
we may very well see a pullback in
amazon stock after the pandemic
so it's not realistic to expect this
growth rate for another six years
to put this in perspective amazon would
have to be an
eight to eight and a half trillion
dollar company for jeff to reach the
trillion dollar mark
and that's very unlikely within the next
six years
especially with them selling billions of
dollars worth of stock every year
now he is investing this money into blue
origin which does have
exponential growth prospects however the
main bottle cap in this sector
is the growth of the space marketplace
i'm sure
in 20 to 30 years he could grow this
into a multiple trillion dollar company
but within the next 10 years blue origin
is unlikely to really grow its net worth
significantly
simply because the space marketplace
just won't be ready in that time frame
at least not in the trillion dollar
range blue origin may however
become a few hundred billion dollar
company by then giving jeff bezos
another 100 to 200 billion dollars
but again amazon would have to account
for about 800 to 900 billion of jeff's
wealth
so if we input a more realistic growth
rate of 20
for jeff's net worth it would take him
about nine more years to reach the
trillion dollar mark
or basically until 2030 but even that is
quite high
and it's very possible that amazon is
closer to market performance
over the next decade thus with a 10
growth rate
it would take 17 years or near the end
of the 2030s
so though jeff bezos could reach the
trillion dollar mark
this decade if amazon continues with its
exponential run
this is not very likely a more realistic
time frame would be 2030-2035
elon musk on the other hand has a much
better shot at reaching the 20
mark within this decade as his companies
are still in the exponential growth
phase unlike amazon
similar to jeff bezos most of enos
wealth growth over the next decade
will likely come from tesla as opposed
to spacex
due to limiting factors in the space
market elon musk
currently owns 19 of tesla however
he gets another one percent of the total
outstanding shares of tesla
for every 50 billion increase in market
cap up until a market valuation
of 650 billion dollars of course he also
has to hit revenue
and income based milestones to cash out
on this incentive
but assuming he does he would roughly
grow his position to 25
of tesla and that's assuming he gets no
more stock
after 650 billion evaluation and the
respective milestones
as for how much profit tesla could be
making in the next 10 years
if tesla is able to grow into a high
volume electric car maker
that itself would give elon hundreds of
billions of dollars
currently volkswagen and toyota push 10
million cars per year
while tesla on the other hand is
targeting to push just
hundred thousand cars this year or just
five percent
but this is mostly due to manufacturing
limitations
as opposed to demand limitations right
now
tesla is aiming to produce five hundred
thousand cars per factory
and are building two factories one in
berlin and one in austin
which will put their total factory count
at five
just achieving their production numbers
per factory after these two factories
are up and running
tesla would be able to produce two and a
half million cars per year
if they continue building two factories
per year they would easily have
20 to 25 factories by the end of the
decade producing about 10 to 12 million
cars per year
as long as demand is able to scale up
which is quite likely
given decreases in carb prices and the
fact that both volkswagen and toyota
are already able to support these
numbers tesla should be able to get to
at least 10 million cars sold
per year by the end of the decade
currently
tesla doesn't profit very much as most
of their profits go towards building new
factories
and other capital investments however as
they scale up
the cost of building factories will
become a smaller and smaller portion of
their income
assuming they achieve a net profit
margin of five percent which is less
than toyota's net profit margin of seven
percent
and about the same as volkswagen's net
profit margin
tesla would achieve a yearly profit of
15 billion dollars
at an average car price of 30 000 which
is significantly less than their current
average car price
with their current p e ratio of over 900
which is the ratio between their profit
and market valuation
they would actually be over a 10
trillion dollar company
but assuming the pe ratio settles down
to something much more reasonable
like a hundred which is less than where
amazon currently sits
tesla would be worth one and a half
trillion dollars giving elon musk 375
billion dollars
giving him the same 100 to 200 billion
dollars from his rocket company spacex
elon musk would be worth 500 to 600
billion dollars by the end of the decade
and that's the very minimum as that
completely ignores tesla's autonomous
driving technology
the robo taxi network through battery
technology
and their solar business which is where
tesla will get most of its profit
instead of selling those 10 million cars
if tesla's full self-driving technology
is ready in the next 10 years
they can put those 10 million cars into
the robo taxi network
from which each car is expected to
profit 30 000
per year at that rate this fleet alone
will bring in 300 billion dollars in
profit per year
even at just a p e ratio of 10 that
would make tesla a three trillion dollar
company
giving musk 750 billion dollars
but it's likely that tesla will have a p
e ratio in the 30s
as that's what other mature tech
companies like microsoft and apple boast
at a pu ratio of 30 tesla would be a 9
trillion dollar company giving musk 2.25
trillion
and that's still completely ignoring the
growth of a robo taxi fleet
as well as any profit from licensing the
autopilot software
or battery technology to other car
manufacturers it's also ignoring the
entirety of the solar business
not to mention musk space company boring
company and neuralink
which could give him multiple trillion
each with all this being said
even if jeff is able to beat elon to the
first trillion
elon will surely be the richest
trillionaire by far soon after
heck he may even reach 10 trillion by
the time he dies
do you guys think anyone else could
reach a trillion faster comment that
down below
also drop a like if you guys appreciate
the depth of his analysis
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one